intention of the error in addition to do
you do re lines of the next generation
you look back covan tim gayda maixentais
de mort d'ânee irigo european
institutions have to gather taken
proceeding swift and strong action first
we the image here all the food
designed to both to recovery and to be
no more this symbol a network nothing
filter error websites like
n 2 to seed fbi norrington ce
workshop commission and former member
states and results are here to day
twenty itself state of death metal
recovery  brazilian lines or
commissions which has been sheringham
and chaos and displays line
fract element with pau orthez phobos of
this parliament indicates anne so this gesture 6t
their european countries said mario lafrance
european studio sunrise period
there are two that feeds goes to the games  and
commission fees a sprint to scott
weese own retail king lisa the match
of the weekend was born swift her week
except from planes wilder institutions country
q  ui is in this context that a thrift store
exchange in parliament is different
style of this civil trial and
originals
the citizens business is right thing for
se porte
time is au tsl ce speech and quality
masculine and transparent way from de
cowes said we expect the first official
zwei de commission have ten to sixteen
weeks off de plug in the  course of
the moon in two commissions of
commissions of 2012 is certainly corn
october 3 to soon as possible to make sure
that share since financing and start
from being the citizens and business
during the same as one of the presidents c
is what camping european
parliament in front of this process is
appropriate five ministers speak to the
chairman of the committee rule
c  her mr president ladies and
gentlemen deputies
it is good to be back in strasbourg
there is the last plenary as
we had in this hemicycle
it was in February 2020 it was
more than a year ago
and  how the world has changed since
we swim there but would not imagine war
while a global pandemic would put
our economies to a stop would weigh
heavily on our societies and
upset our way of life
this pandemic has cost
our societies and our economies horribly dear  it is
indisputable but it is there it
has also mobilized us and challenged us
to design and implement
extraordinary solutions with the
strong support of this parliament and our
member states
we have launched financial assistance measures
unprecedented and
we did it with record speed
next generation you give our union
the power to invest hundreds of
billions in a joint recovery that
we don't have we have the most  and
need and to invest in our
common priorities with next generation and the eu we are
transforming our continent for the
board and defining the future
we are digitizing our economies we
are making the green deal for europe a
reality and we are making our societies
stronger is more  resilient our
plan your 750 billion euros it's the
biggest recovery project deploy in
europe rain the marshall plan
it's the recovery in europe needs
today and for the future
yes 5 6 2
because  we live in d
our diva is an ode in europe
insavalor pin centro least in french
origins our destinies with great had
remained one only god and nature and has
to fight hispanic at 0 pin
junior originally explains the nhtsa m this
proves france  and in any case leave
regions studied at 25 f bayrou state of
grace in the mode a sorting between colonizers
pin commission working island day and
night garden in macao in any case david
young european payment soweto
families in w  izz air
ah yes because with about to begin the blind
side of manhattan
florine from coming weeks haptonomy to
come here twenty free nationals
discipline cd v rik their message
you paint houses news star in south louisiana
in to be or not that into you tube
lynette saves  brousse du rove
competitiveness english sky and is
planned private radio show rickie lee
jones turned mafio the soloist shoshana
turn climate or the crane 9 luckily it
will be fun bike and run by tom stephens
6 billion to be digitized road in basel
an infrastructure the lectra station  in the
final round to the mobilities and not to the
rejected the former canary invests
divia flight of indians alves only works
on the edge of the abyss in europe emphasizes
bruce power and whimsical to these
gentlemen to this love 6 facing one man
at a time l  english modernize or we
said dynamic it's a cabal
nice souls 6th dykes italy between bright
lights stedfast mastery stars
have just been the best at this title  e
in cdd vitaliser in question we live
but annex generation y or fallout
beispiel zheng he and other folk and
grain corridor on tarpaulin right right
now spain and things digital isiro
the clues therefore leave enormous our
ndpc a single life that we form
modern  this microprocessor cup to the
stage in full form of a date in nice
generation take advantage of the vote in front of the
mayor of stars we see a digital
skills nina menchov abc investing
in your guitar bass player in the finger
the rise peyrelongue investment in
to cut down yang have  demoralized
solar university one of six young
comedians honor your members now we
have to employment species to elsewhere
to botmeur
in hong kong in bio and luis enrique this
you have been through the night the
nation france added m valliot y
contribute we continue to win it you
very first time there would you do so
let's make it right let's get it right
because he the day then union
exporters like sony continue  to be
available to death castries and that it
takes the objectives we have agreed upon at
the dream house of lies saint jean in
paris will be present to slide
objectives cdn stones and from what we
say so for anything kwaï many to
come and fish there  in november next generation
you we decided to make our hikari
european regions week april a
shareholder is tony okendo the back side
dead match of antoine individual we carry
plants and recruits
hyundai developer hyun jung woo ping eye in the
secret world without djanguinaba before
next  generation yu chun at the match
weekend
the president of sos side showed the
political groupies of the people's party
they allegedly stole my phone from
[Music
] germany